All right. Hello everyone. Welcome to my
series, Worthless to Wall Street. This
is episode number 17. If you guys don't
know the rules, basically a long ass
time ago, I started with 5 mil and I've
been merching my way on up. If you guys
want to, well, actually, if you guys
want to check it out, just go check out
my channel. You can watch from episode
one all the way down to now if you want.
If you want to get caught up, go through
some lower tier merches. But right now,
we This is not all we have. We have
about 134 mil, I do believe. Uh was able
to make 14 mil last episode. Looking to
up that this time. And we're starting
off with a heavy ballista merch. Those
are going for 100k each. So if I'm able
to merge my GE limit, I'll make 600k.
And then, you know, just got a just got
a stray third age plate body just
sitting there buying, hoping to make a
little bit of money off that. So,
welcome to the episode. We're going to
get into some more m we're going to get
into some more merches. All right. So, I
just, you know, unexpectedly fell
asleep. I guess I laid down, watched a
little bit of Monday Night Football, and
boom, gone for 4 hours. So, it's 2:30
a.m. Um, made 7GP off of all the death
runes. So, there's a good, you know,
just 70k. That was actually really
quick. The ballistas, I think I was able
to make what, like 80 70 to 80k, I
think. Almost. Yeah, pretty much 90k off
of all these. So, that's 630 minus the
100 that we took to find the margins.
So, good 530 there. So, 600k in total.
Uh, somehow the 30 plate body still
hasn't sold, so we'll wait for that
overnight. Uh until all right, until
then going to try to figure out
something else that I can do in the
meantime. I meant to uh I don't even
know what I meant to do, but I
accidentally just ended at the last
recording. So if that didn't line up
well, then uh my bad. All right,
morning. I am uh so annoyed with these
ferocters to be totally honest with you.
Only one sold. Oh my god. It's just like
I do not understand. I don't know why
they keep going down, bro. I have no
clue. So, we're just going to try to buy
another one. All right. 74. I mean,
that's the thing. There's just not
enough of these being bought, I think,
honestly. Like, god damn it, bro. All
the time. Hey, at least we were able to
sell off something. So, we got some of
the ferro scepters to sell off. As you
can see here, I made, you know, like
210k off probably all of them. So, it's
cool. 800k flip. I don't even know what
I bought this [__] third age plate
body for anymore, but I'm going to list
it down to say 9. Yeah. Yeah. 96 999.
Okay. Please, for the love of God, sell
on for that. That That was what I wanted
to list it down for. Hopefully, it
sells. We'll still make a few hundredk,
but I just don't want to get, you know,
I don't I don't want it to drop on me.
That's it. That's all that's all I want.
All right. So, buying a couple pharaoh
scepters right now. I was able to sell
off the 30 plate body for 3 to 400k
profit if I remember correctly. Um, also
going to have my main buy over these
cannonballs since I did that with money
on my merch and I was just kind of
buying them for my main account. And I
probably still will continue to do it,
but I think from now on I'm probably
just going to do it with money for my
main and just have that be on the side.
All right. So then, as you saw with the
ferroceptors buying, this is kind of
what idea I had in mind. So I'm going to
see how much I can buy this charge
ferroceptor for and uh see if we can
make any money off of charging them. So
as you can see, 7299 and 7064 is what I
bought them for. So that'd be a 230k
profit. And they might actually get
bought more because, you know, people
actually need like charged ones. I don't
think people need the uncharge as much
anymore. They used to for like the oult
alter, I think, for your house, but I
think that that's kind of gone out the
window now since, you know, it's been a
while and everyone has it, I guess. All
right, so there we go. Able to sell on
two of the heavy ballistas for 120k
profit. We're going to try to sell on
another two for so then in total get
480k. I ended up losing about 70k
finding the margin. So that'd be 410 in
total. As you can see there, five
ferosceptors for 7272. And I bought them
all for about 7.07 mil. So that's 200k.
That's about a mill. And the ring of
sufferings, I really have no clue. I
think I made 75k so far on those. So not
a whole lot in general. So all right,
just woke up. I'm a little sick, which
kind of sucks,
but going to sell on the arcane.
Apparently selling for 20 or 76 mil,
which means I would make 100k off of
that, which is pretty cool. Uh the
gilded skims, they went up a ton, but
apparently they're back down now. I keep
refreshing the OS buddy page. You get
something else every time. But right
now, I seem to be getting around
1288k. We'll go for that. Um that'll
give us a good what 220k profit off each
of them if they are able to sell. So in
total, these slips would be worth one uh
1.1 mil maybe. All right. So to kind of
show you what we have done, we ended up
selling the arcane for 76. So, good 500k
profit there. I'm sick as [__] Uh 222k
profit off of two of the gold or gilded
se skimars, we should get another one.
So, that'd be
666k. Pretty lit. Um that'll put us at
1.1 milish. And then on the pharaoh
scepters right now, if these are all
able to buy and sell, I bought them all
for 36 mil in total and could sell them
on for 37.8. So, that would mean we've
merged 2.9 mil in the last little bit.
So, that's pretty good. All right. So,
pretty crazy. um was able to merge a
little bit, I guess. So, as you can see
here, I was able to sell on pretty much
or I sold on two of the Pharaoh scepters
for 370K profit and then the other three
for 180k profit. And literally as soon
as I got on, my last gilded skim sold,
which was was sitting in there for like
4 hours. That was really good timing.
So, going to take the jar of darkness
out cuz I was just a little, you know,
hopeful buy. And we are at 139 mil. So,
that's pretty good. Uh 139.3. So, we're
going to continue and uh find some more
stuff. All right. So, able to sell off
some Carol's leather tops. Able to make
200k. Well, 240k. I was I made 60k of
flip and I had to buy the margins. Then
with tormented bracelets, I made 200k
because I had to buy the margin which
was 100k. So, in total there, we made a
good I don't know [__] 440k or so.
And then with the ferroceptors right
now, they're still buying. All right.
So, I haven't recorded a clip on this
account for a while, but I've been doing
a little bit of stuff. Um, pretty much I
don't know. Well, I don't I don't even
know what I could say. I lost a ton of
money on Ferroceptors. Uh, Ferroceptors
3 I ended up charging some that I bought
for like 7.1 and selling them off for
like or 7.2 and sell them off for like
7.05 and uh that I mean so I lost 150k
on like 10 or 11 of them. I was going to
use it for a video but decided against
it. Um, so I lost like 1.6 mil there.
Uh, however, I was able to make about
probably 300k a ferroceptor off of
these. So, I probably made about three
mil doing that. And then on top of that,
right now, as you can see, I'm buying
some ferroceptors for 6.5 and selling
them on for practically seven. So, I'm
getting about a 500k merch just for
charging them, which is pretty insane.
And uh, heavy ballistas. I was able to
merch seven. I had to buy the margin on
one of them. I believe the margin was
about 80k or so, if I check here. Yeah,
it was about 80k. So, 80 times what? I
think six because yeah 80 times six. So
I don't even I don't even know what the
[__] is that 480k. So we're doing pretty
good. We're doing pretty good. Um yeah,
I haven't recorded a lot of clips
lately. So I got to kind of got to get
back on my grind. All right, it is the
morning. I'm going to go ahead and
collect all of this and end out this
offer. So as you can see, we still have
six ferosceptors, which you know,
probably sell for around I would say
this price maybe. So that's 40 mils. So,
in total, we're up to 140. But you also
have to remember, well, I guess I never
mentioned this, but I bought a bond on
this account for my hardcore iron man.
So, that was about 3.4 mil that I'm
going to have to transfer over for my
main. So, in total right now, we're
about at 143 144 mil, which is a decent
amount of progress. And I'm pretty
excited to just see if there's any
margins on the ferroceptors right now.
So, give me a second. Realistically, I'm
just going to sell off one and then
start buying for whatever price it sells
off for cuz I know that there's going to
be margins. actually. Well, maybe not.
I'm not entirely sure now. Um, let's see
what this goes for. So, we're going to
buy one of these 6950. It's not really
worth it right now, but the one thing I
am going to do is try and sell off these
ferroceptors that I do have and try to
make a profit by just lowering the buy
price. So, as you can see, I'm still
making 350K off of each one of these
cells. So, what I'm trying to do is get
that person's offer out. And even if
not, I still end up making a ton of
money anyways. So, as you can see, I
don't think I'm going to get his offer
out, but I'm sure gonna dump some
Pharaoh scepters on him if I can't. So,
we do what we can. So, there we go. Sold
all of them off. I know my voice is
probably disgusting right now, but there
we go. So, yeah, 7 mil actually right
there. That actually sold on. So, that's
142.3. I was actually really off. I
ended up getting
145.7 or so mills. So, we'll find
something else, I guess, right now, cuz
it kind of gets repetitive with the
pharaoh scepters, and they don't have
that good of a margin right now.
Anyways, all right. So, I've been
merching a little bit, as you can see.
I've bought the uh torture amulets,
found that there was like an 84k margin.
Then, I was able to buy and sell off
four. So, in total there after, you
know, making back the money I had to pay
for finding the margin. I ended up
making about 240k. Then, at that point,
I bought another three. Accidentally
sold two of them off to someone else
that was merching and one went to myself
cuz I still had an offer in to buy one
more. and uh ended up selling that for
another 80k. So made 300 some oddk from
that. The tyrannical ring actually right
now has a crazy merch as you can see
6.13 mil and I bought it for 5.6. So
that was a 500k merch on tyrannical
ring. So definitely looking forward to
trying to do that a little bit more. But
the zenite jewelry actually seems like
it has a decent margin. So I'm just
going to mess around with that. All
right. So here we go. As you can see,
the necklace of anguish really has a
good margin right now. About 300k and
I've been able to merge. This will be
the fifth one. Um, whenever I bought it,
I saw how high it was above like the
estimated price. So, I didn't even sell
it on, so I didn't have to find the
margin. So, I kind of just made it up on
my own. But, uh, yeah, this would be 1.5
mil merch with all these pretty much.
Maybe like 1.4. All right. So, at this
point, I've been merching a lot of
necklaces of anguish. I think that this
would with these two being sold off,
that would be seven, which would be
about 2 mil in total. I also have
another two selling, which would put me
up to about 2.6, six, but I have bought
I believe 11. So, I don't know what the
uh what the limit is per hour on these
things. I'm going to keep trying. I
figured it would be either eight or 10,
but it doesn't look like either one of
those.
So, I don't know. I don't know. We'll
continue. Honestly, at this point, I
don't even know if these things have
limits. Like I don't know if they they
just, you know, didn't even consider
this item when they made like GE limits,
but at this point I'm at a pretty high
amount of them. I I don't even know.
Like you Yeah, they just keep going. I
don't I don't know. And I'm making like
250k now off each one. So it's it's
great. I don't know. I got no complaints
over here. Ring of sufferings are
finally buying. I'm probably going to
list them up a little higher just cuz
they took this long to buy. So, I'm
guessing that I could sell them on for
more than I initially believed that I
could, but uh yeah. All right. Just sold
off a Ring of Suffering for about a 200k
profit. Um other than that, the Ring of
Suffering actively traded price was like
13.4 mil for some reason. I don't know
if someone was able to sell one off for
that or happened to sell one off for
that. But as you can see, we had a
little bit of stuff going on. I guess I
had a lot of uh anguish flips. I think I
sold off six as you can see here for
14.5 or 14.9 almost which probably made
me about 1.1 mil. Um I'm going to take
everything out and we're at is that
48? Oh my god, we're at 148 mil. I also
have 3.4 mil in the bank for my bond. So
that's 152 mil. Oh my god, we're killing
it this episode. Those angler slips were
insane. I'm going to check and uh see if
there's any other sort of zenite stuff
that I can do. But yeah, this has been
crazy. Finished off a couple more
merches on tormented bracelets. As you
can see, I was actually getting some
pretty crazy margins on these. I got I
bought and sold the first one. There was
a 300k margin. Then I was able to buy
off I think and probably sell, as you
can see, I sold three another one. I
probably made in total maybe two to two
and a half mil off of these. I'm not
entirely sure in total, but we're up to
150.1 mil plus a 3.4, so 153.5. All
right, so I was able to merge four
torture amulets. Made about 100k off of
each of them, but I did have to buy the
margin. So 300k profit there. Going to
go and probably just I don't I mean this
the the zeni jewelry is just so good
right now. There's no reason for me to
hop off of it now. So I'm going to see
what I can do with other stuff. All
right, so just to kind of update you
guys on where I'm at, what I've been
doing. Just been flipping the rest of
the pharaoh scepters. was able to sell I
think all of them off for 6849 which
means I think I have no clue how much
money I made on them. Probably like 350k
on all of them. So as you can see here
we got 151.7 mil plus 3.4 mil or
whatever. So that's 155ish mil. So uh
yeah going to go to the gym. Going to
try to buy some tormented bracelets
while I'm gone. I don't know if I've hit
my 4 hour limit on these things. I don't
think I have. I think I just got
undercut. But going to throw in an offer
for let's say this price 14712 and try
to buy 10 I guess. Why not? We'll see
how that goes. Hopefully they don't drop
on me though cuz most of the other Zenai
jewelry is lower. And uh yeah. All
right. Watching the Michigan game right
now. Just got back from the gym. And I
ended up selling off all these tormented
bracelets as you can see. 210K profit
off of all of them. So 89.6 is what I
ended up selling them for. Bought them
all for 88.3. So a good 1.3 mil profit.
We'll move on to another item now. All
right. So about to go to bed. My voice
probably sounds like complete [__] right
now. But uh I made about I don't know
170 180k off of five of these, but I
mean, you know, it is what it is. I'm
just going to take all this money out
and then you guys can kind of have an
idea as far as to where we are. Let me
uh throw this in real quick. All right,
so as you can see there, 27.3 added on
to this and you will get pretty much
what 155 plus the 3.4 in the bank. So
158.4 for lit. Nothing bought,
obviously, as you can tell. I'm pretty
[__] tired, but we're going to
[__] we're going to find some items
to merge. I don't know why I'm so tired,
bro. All right, so here we are. Looks
like these things aren't going to buy.
I've had the offers in for about 20
minutes now. Nothing's bought. But, as
you can see, I was able to flip a couple
uh Necklace of Anguish for 120K. I had
to buy the margins, so made about 360K
there. Made 180K off one of those flips
cuz I had to, you know, make back the
margins. though. Made like 500k. Nothing
too much. All right, here we are. So,
sold off all of our Zenite shards. Not
that I really informed you guys about
them in the first place, but we uh we
barely made any money off of them. I
bought them for
1183K. Um they dropped a lot. Their
margins were a lot higher. Obviously, I
wouldn't have bought those if I would
have known that. I made a little bit of
money off these rings of suffering. As
you can see, I made like I was making
like 105k off of each one or so. And
then ferroceptors. Right now there's a
pretty decent margin. I'm going to buy
another ferroceptor scepter 3 so I can
see what I could be able to charge it
and get it to sell for. All right, so
here we are able to sell off my bond for
like a 200k loss after, you know, I just
wanted to use it for another account,
but then didn't end up using it. And
then 68 mil over here. Barely made any
money on the pharaoh scepters. Probably
like 5 600k in total, but uh there we
go. So as you can see, 96 mil. However,
I did just buy a uh imbued heart for my
main account real quick just to go ahead
and make a video with it. So, right now
that would mean I'm up to
about 159 mil almost. So, that's pretty
cool. We're going to get on to doing
some other stuff though while I uh go to
the wreck. Well, that was more
successful than I thought it would be.
Um before I left to go to the gym, I
ended up buying my third age robe or
third age plate body, what the hell? And
I ended up selling it off for 500k while
I was gone. So, pretty quick profit
there. Nothing too shabby. We'll try to
find some items now. All right. So, as
I've I guess I haven't said anything,
but alls I've been doing is just buying
some anguishes. I was making like 90k
off of all of them. And then bought some
torches and made about 70k off of all
them. So, I think somewhere in here we
probably made about 1 to 1.5 mil. I
don't know how many of what we bought
and sold. I'm so confused. All right.
So, we just got done charging um nine
ferroceptors. As you can see, I bought
it for 6850. Uh the ferroceptors 3.
Okay, so I'm making 145k per charge. So,
uh, somewhere around 1.2 1.3 mil or so
from all of these ferroceptors that are
in my bank. Also forgot I had a cool
500k just sitting here in loopass of
keys in my bank that I, you know,
probably had from a previous merch. So,
I'm just going to sell those on real
quick. All right, so that imbued heart
that I used for my other video actually
in the time that I bought it went up 1.7
mil. So, we were able to make that much
money off of that. We have 142 mil right
here, 142.6, and 20.7 here. here. So
once I take that out, that's
163.4 mil, which is honestly insane. I
don't know how much progress we've made
this episode, but I know it is a lot.
All right, I can barely talk cuz I am
just so [__] sick right now. But as
you can see, we have one tormented
bracelet left to sell off. I know I
didn't go through these kind of things
that much, but one thing I did notice is
there is a [__] ton of merches that I
did this or this video. This video is
going to be long as [__] now that I
start to edit it, but I was able to
merge off about four, I think, tortures.
So, we made 360K there. Uh, the
sufferings, we made about 400k with all
those. And then we did merge some
tormented bracelets as well, as you can
see. I don't know exactly what I bought
them for cuz I can't see it anymore, but
I know I made around 100K off of those,
but then I ended up losing 100k on the
one I just insta sold. But, we're going
to collect all of this and see where we
are at. So, we are at 164 mil. That is
honestly just an insane profit that we
made this episode. This was over the
span of about six days, I would say. So,
I made 30 mil in 6 days, which is
actually pretty insane. That's about Oh,
god. 30 mil in six days. It's 5 mil.
Okay, we're good. We're good. I thought
I was going to mess that up. I knew it
was pretty simple, but 5 mil a day,
that's actually that's literally insane.
I I'm I honestly am not even on that
merching that much. We just had some
crazy ass flips this episode. So, hope
you guys enjoyed. If you guys did, feel
free to hit that like button. If you
guys have any ways that you want me to
improve, go ahead and comment about them
down below. If you guys want to see all
my other worthless or Wall Street
episodes, you can check out my channel.
There's a playlist for that. And if you
guys want to be informed as soon as the
next one goes live, hit that sub button.
Nonetheless, with that being said, I
hope you guys have a wonderful day and
peace.
[Music]
I for